clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci abonne toi ça va on a juste
eu fait que ce soit en papier là je
rentrais une crise l'orgasme et on m'a
dit que ça marchait bien pour se calmer
donc tous bords gas oil
je bois une crise d'angoissé plus tôt si
c'est ça à ça du coup le sac en papier
pour respirer dans l'eau je vais changer
de sac du coup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une crise d'angoissé est ce que ça vous
est déjà arrivé genre imagine que vous
êtes tout seul chez vous et tout d'un
coup ça va pas vous est oppressé vous
respirez mal votre coeur s'emballe vous
transpirez vous avez chaud ça va pas du
tout vous est submergé vous avez
l'impression vous allez vous écroulez
vous arrivez à rien et surtout vous
n'arrivez pas à vous arrêter
alors déjà qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire qu'est ce qui se passe
exactement à ce que c'est une crise
d'angoissé
est ce que c'est de l'anxiété parce que
c'est un coup de déprime est ce que
c'est du stress tout ça c'est des trucs
qui se ressemblent pas mal et qui se
manifeste un peu de la même manière et
surtout est pas si facile de faire le
tri tout seul
si c'était facile on se retrouvera pas
dans cet état là donc on va procéder
autrement savoir ce qui vous arrive
c'est avant tout savoir d'où vient le
problème
ça c'est le meilleur moyen de le
combattre et de faire en sorte que ça
vous arrive plus il réfléchir à tête
reposée en discuter avec des proches
c'est bien mais ça suffit pas toujours
alors déjà si vous êtes sujet à ce genre
de crise allait en parler avec un
professionnel un ou une psychologue par
exemple ou alors un ou une psychiatre si
vous connaissez pas la différence entre
les deux je vous renvoie à ma vidéo dans
laquelle on en a déjà parlé ce genre de
personnes des professionnels ils ont un
double avantage sur vos proches
1 en plus d'être bienveillant et d'être
là pour vous aider
comme vos proches sûrement eux ils sont
pas impliqués personnellement donc ils
sont neutres et 2 c'est leur métier et
tout ça ça va vous aider à y voir plus
clair
bon mais ça c'est un travail qui va
payer sur le long terme et avant de
parler de la crise à proprement parler
on va voir ce qu'on peut faire aussi à
moyen terme pour ça on va imaginer
l'angoissé comme un sac à dos
ce sac à dos il est rempli de trucs on
va dire des cailloux plus ou moins lourd
et on le porte toutes et tous sur nos
épaules
des fois ça va il est tellement léger
qu'on remarque même pas qu'il est là
mais quand il se remplit un petit peu
trop on n'arrive plus à avancer avec
il devient trop lourd et on finit par
s'effondrer sous son poids c'est la
crise le truc c'est que souvent on a
tendance à se dire que pour ça s'arrête
il faut que j'enlève ce sac de mondo que
je le balance comme ça tout d'un coup et
après je suis tranquille sauf que nous
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
l'idée c'est plutôt d'empêcher qu'ils
deviennent trop lourd et donc de lever
d petit à petit en enlevant un par un
les cailloux qu'il ya dedans alors bien
sûr il ya des gros cailloux genre des
parpaings limite des rochers alors cela
vous allez peut-être mettre un peu de
temps à les enlever
vous verrez ça avec vos petits mais vous
pouvez commencer par enlever des
cailloux pas trop lourd en faisant ça
vous alléger votre sac et voulait
empêcher de vous écraser
alors ces cailloux qu'il ya dans votre
sac c'est quoi ça peut être la pression
que vous vous mettez donc dans un
premier temps foutez vous un peu la paix
vous avez le droit de pas tout bien
faire vous avez le droit de vous planter
vous avez le droit de pas aller bien
laissez nous tranquilles et al'inverse
pensez à vous dire merci bravo bien joué
quand vous faites des trucs cool ces
cailloux ça peut aussi être de la
frustration
donc s'il ya des trucs que vous avez
envie de faire ou envie de dire va
essayer dans la limite du raisonnable
bien sûr ça peut aussi être de la
culpabilité donc si vous visez mal un
truc si vous avez besoin de régler une
vieille histoire avec quelqu'un faites
le ça peut être une relation qui vous
fait du mal parlez-en avec la personne
concernée essayer d'arranger les choses
ou dites lui que vous la verrez plus et
pourquoi vous la verrez plus du temps
vous êtes audible ça peut être une
inquiétude donc à poser des questions
par les ans bon vous avez compris ça
peut être plein de trucs chercher ce qui
vous pèse et agissez et vous verrez que
souvent agir c'est juste en parler vider
son sac
bon ok vous avez pris rendez vous chez
un psy vous avez commencé à vider votre
sac ça vous promet un avenir meilleur
mais je vous ai prévenus ça marche pas
forcément tout de suite d'autant que
pendant ce temps là votre sac
il peut continuer à se remplir avec des
nouveaux cailloux et que parfois des bus
et bien il peut se remplir plus vite
qu'on le vide donc vous pouvez continuer
à faire des crises
du coup je vais vous donner cinq
conseils pour faire passer une crise
d'angoissé bon soyons clairs la vous
fait une crise d'angoissé votre sac
il est plein vous êtes écrasé sous son
poids c'est pas le moment d'essayer de
le vider ce n'est pas le moment
d'essayer de comprendre le pourquoi le
comment le quoi le caisse là il va
falloir être pragmatique et s'attaquer
aux signes parce que quand on fait une
crise on se retrouve bloqué dans une
boucle infernale
on va pas bien on a des signes
physique qui apparaissent çà nous
angoisse encore plus on va encore moins
bien etc
c'est un cercle vicieux et il faut en
sortir vous allez voir ça consiste
souvent à tchité sont trente corps c'est
à dire à faire disparaître les signes
physiques qui montre que ça va pas bien
pour qui croit que ça va mieux et que du
coup on finissent par aller vraiment
mieux pour ça voilà ce qu'on peut faire
faire baisser la température clairement
vous êtes en surchauffe
d'ailleurs vous avez chaud la première
étape ça va être de se rafraîchir un
petit peu dans un premier temps pas trop
compliqué buvez un verre d'eau fraîche
en plus de vous procurer un peu de
fraîcheur ça va vous forcer à vous
bouger pour aller remplir votre verre
une fois que c'est fait retournez pas
sous votre plaide ou sous votre couette
profitez en pour aller prendre une
douche
alors l'idée c'est pas forcément de
prendre une douche glacée encore que si
vous avez l'impression que ça vous fait
du bien
pourquoi pas mais là prenez pas trop
chaude en tout cas oubliez pas l'idée
c'est de faire baisser la température
est de vous donner un petit coup de
fouet
et puis en plus vous avez su et donc ça
vous fera pas de calmer son coeur et
reprendre son souffle
et ouais parce que les deux sont liés le
coeur et la respiration ça marche main
dans la main et comme vous pouvez pas
contrôler votre coeur directement vous
allez jouer sur la respiration avec des
petits exercices simples en ralentissant
progressivement votre respiration vous
allez aussi faire baisser votre
fréquence cardiaque et revenir à un état
plus calme pour ça vous vous installez
confortablement vous fermez les yeux et
vous vous concentrer sur vos mouvements
respiratoires
vous prenez des inspirations de plus en
plus longues en gonflant votre ventre et
vous expirez de plus en plus longuement
si vous arrivez à faire ça comme ça tout
seul
pas très bien si vous avez du mal vient
des applications de cohérence cardiaque
ou de méditation
je vous mets les liens dans la
description au début ça peut être un
petit peu compliqué parce que là aussi
c'est un cercle vicieux comme vous
respirez vite vous évacuer beaucoup de
gaz carbonique de co2 votre corps il
s'en rend compte il pense qu'il ya un
problème et du coup ils accélèrent
encore plus la respiration et en plus le
manque de co2 ça perturbe l'absorption
du calcium c'est ça qui peut vous donner
des fourmillements des crampes des
tremblements et c'est donc dans ce
cas-là respirer dans un sac en papier
pour
vous étouffer ou dans vos mains comme ça
comme ça vous allez respirer le co2 que
vous expirez directement votre corps va
se rendre compte que ça serait équilibré
et il va calmer la respiration
alors faites pas ça trop longtemps parce
que trop de co2 c'est pas bien non plus
quand vous voyez que ça commence à
passer mme a fait l'exercice dont on a
parlé avant faire diversion en situation
de crise c'est le système limbique de
votre cerveau qui prend le dessus
celui qui est responsable des émotions
comme la peur par exemple et c'est
difficile de le contrôler ce qu'il faut
c'est réussir à stimuler une autre
partie de votre cerveau le cortex lui
c'est la voie de la réflexion de la
raison et du contrôle de l'humeur et il
est capable de prendre le dessus sur son
collègue un peu vénère pour réussir à
faire ça il faut arriver à trouver une
activité intellectuelle que vous êtes en
état de faire là tout de suite par
exemple des jeux de chiffres ou de
lettres pas trop complexe il ya plein
d'appuis pour ça vous pouvez aussi
épeler des mots à l'envers en commençant
simple et en compliquant le truc de plus
en plus et vous pouvez aussi faire un
baccalauréat
ça marche et chercher la lumière le
manque de lumière ça diminue la
sécrétion de sérotonine qui est un
neurotransmetteur qui jouent un rôle
dans les troubles de l'humeur
alors commencez par allumer les lumières
chez vous c'est bien mais là on parle de
la vraie lumière la lumière du jour
donc une fois que vous avez fait les
trucs dont on a parlé avant et que vous
êtes un petit peu d'aplomb sortez de
chez vous même si c'est l'hiver et qui
fait gris ya toujours un peu de lumière
et même s'il fait 3 bat ça va vous
rafraîchir un peu et ça va nous booster
trois autres intérêt à aller faire un
tour ça va continuer à faire diversion
ça va vous forcer à bouger et ça va
aussi vous permettre de ne pas rester
seuls avoir de la compagnie même si
c'est la dernière chose dont on a envie
quand on est au plus fort de la crise ça
n'a que des avantages
déjà ça vous permet de faire diversion
de stimuler votre cortex
en discutant ou en faisant des jeux
ensuite un simple contact physique avec
quelqu'un qu'on aime bien évidemment ça
favorise la sécrétion d'ocytocine
l'hormone de l'amour qui elle-même
favorise la sécrétion de sérotonine dont
on a déjà parlé
et qui stabilisent l'humeur et permet de
gérer le stress donc fait des câlins si
vous avez la chance d'avoir dans votre
entourage quelqu'un de confiance que
vous aimez bien et qui est là pour vous
appeler le peuple est là mais appeler
cette personne là elle peut passer vous
cherchez vous pouvez la rejoindre
quelque part hop un petit ugg ont fait
un tour on discute un petit peu ça fait
du bien et surtout ça évite que la crise
recommence alors je sais le problème
dans ces cas là c'est que spontanément
on a le réflexe de faire tout le
contraire de ce qu'ils font on a
tendance à aller dans le sens de la
crise en restant tout seul
recroquevillé sans bouger au chaud sous
la couette dans le noir mais une fois
qu'on a pris conscience qu'on avait
besoin de toul inverse
une fois qu'on a compris comment ça
marche une fois qu'on a essayé et qu'on
a vu que ça marchait
les fois suivantes c'est beaucoup plus
facile ses conseils que je vous donne
ils sont peut-être pas tous fait pour
vous l'important c'est de trouver ce qui
vous convienne à vous d'ailleurs ils
sont peut-être même pas dans la liste
ce qui vous conviennent mais en
cherchant en vous appuyant là dessus
vous aller les trouver
si vous en avez des trucs à vous qui
marche n'hésitez pas à les partager dans
les commentaires ça aidera les autres et
vous verrez ça leur fera du bien et à
vous aussi voit la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo
d'ici là prenez soin de vous et prenez
soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]